a lot of things in history our timing is
very peculiar because in retrospect
things could people can look more
brilliant or necessary than they
actually were so the fact that Bill
Clinton faced George George Bush the
first George Bush in 92 was just the
perfect moment for him in that sense
people were really bored with the Reagan
era they didn't like Bush he was
unpopular and it was timing w happen to
have the good fortune of facing Al Gore
in the year 2000 who for all the virtues
of Al Gore and we loved him what ran
probably one of the worst campaigns and
he is not a good campaigner in
retrospect it looks like w you know Karl
Rove that great genius was able to you
know do this electoral magic but in fact
he happened to have the good luck to
face two very weak candidates in Gore
and in Kerry Obama
I'm not saying Obama had luck but the
moment was totally right
people were just viscerally nauseated by
W they had enough of the wars the
incompetence the Katrina the secrecy but
what Obama did that was brilliant and I
talked about it in the 50th law to a
little extent is he understood that the
timing was right and a normal person
would have waited I even thought he
should have waited I was wrong at the
time that it was too early for him
nobody knew him he had no record he's a
black man in America it you know what do
you think it give it some time he
understood that this was the moment if
he waited to 2012 he at that moment
would have gone he would have Hillary
would have won she would have been in a
position of power he would have never
had a chance
this was his moment he opposed the Iraq
war he had momentum and he ran a
brilliant campaign it's a question of
obviously facing a very weak candidate
in John McCain I don't know who they
would have put
who could have possibly posed a greater
threat but Obama was brilliant and how
he he saw that this was the one moment
he had and then he ran for a Democrat
because Democrats generally are pretty
incompetent when it comes to running
elections I'm a Democrat myself so I say
that with you know a little bit of I'm
upset to hear that but someone like John
Kerry typically Democrats don't
understand strategy they're always
reacting to news events and tacking
there here and there depending on what
what's happening they have no sense of
the larger picture Obama was the first
person in my lifetime I can swear the
first candidate in my lifetime who I
could say this man understands strategy
he ran a brilliant campaign a lot of it
based on a consistent message which is
one thing I preach which was his
opposition to the war and change very
well marketing-wise it was brilliant
this was the first man in my lifetime
who I could compare to a FDR or John F
Kennedy two other brilliant campaigners
in history
it's a little hard for me because I have
a problem which is I like him a lot and
I normally don't have this problem
because I normally don't like
politicians so I can view them with some
distance so I'm giving that caveat that
I have this problem I'm not completely
objective he's he has a run up against
some things that he hadn't expected
which for somebody at his age with his
level of executive experience which
wasn't any is going to encounter so he's
at a crossroads he's a very intelligent
man who was very capable of learning
from experience he is finding out what
FDR discovered when he became president
that suddenly you're ruling over
hundreds of people with their own
agendas who come at you with their own
little power bases in their own games
and it's chaos and it's madness now FDR
evolved a very brilliant way of handling
it he had also been governor of New York
he had some executive experience it's
not been even a year that Obama's been
in president as president and so I
preached the idea of patience let us see
how a man or a woman evolves over time
in this position because that's what
shows how great a leader they are going
to be he's at a kind of a crossroads if
he becomes consumed by these pressures
from outside he could end up being a
mediocre president that is always
possible I have faith that he probably
could go in the other direction but an
example would be Afghanistan he
inherited this situation it wasn't his
creation and he inherited a military
complex that peopled with generals that
he had nothing to do with who bring in
all kinds of pressures it's an extremely
complicated situation and it's filled
with all kinds of landmines if he
disregards what his generals are saying
it's going to start looking like the
Democrat who's weak who doesn't as
against war who doesn't understand hard
politic political realities the right
will eat him up and so he's between a
rock and a hard place and some of these
generals that he's inherited are are not
very cooperative with him I've heard
from people that I know I don't have a
lot of connections but I have some that
there is some friction from the old
guard who were there in the Bush years
he's facing a very complicated problem
in how to manage the military brass I
don't think people understand how
difficult and chaotic and complicated it
can be to be the president of the United
States inheriting what he has inherited
in the year 2009 and so we're going to
measure him in the next year I say give
him another year I kind of sick of all
of these progressives who are just
piling on him let's just see things I
don't think he's necessarily someone
who's selling out but it's possible
let's give it some more time